Our simplified answer is 5x cubed y cubed times the cube root of 2x squared y.
Now that's pretty amazing if you got it right on your first try. If you
stumbled a little bit, that's definitely okay, see if you can find your first
mistake in the solution video. Then pause it to see if you can work toward this
answer. We start by simplifying the cube root of 54 and the cube root of 16. We
want to split this up into 27 times 2. This allows us to take the cube root of
27, which we know is 3. The same is true for 16. We split it up into 8 times 2,
so we can take the cube root of 8. So for this first radical, we know the cube
root of 27 equals 3. This 2 stays inside of the radical, since we don't have
the 2 repeated 3 times. Now we can use power divided by root to simplify our
variables. For x, we'll have 8 divided by 3, which equals 2 remainder 2. This
means we'll have x squared on the outside of our radical, And x squared on the
inside of a radical for the variable y we'll have 10 divided by 3 which equals
3 remainder 1. This means we'll have y cubed on the outside of a radical and 1
y or just y on the inside of a radical for the second radical we want to take
the cubed root of 8 which equals 2. This to just stays inside the radical. For
the variable x we use power divided by root, this gives us one remainder two.
So will have one x outside of a radical and x squared inside of a radical. For
y will have two remainder one so y squared on the outside And Y to the 1 on the
inside. We multiply these numbers together to get 9 x cubed, y cubed over here
we multiply them as well. We'll have 4 x to the third and y cubed. Notice that
this term and this term has X cubed Y cubed times the cube root of 2x squared
y. This means that they are like. So really we're just going to do 9 minus 4
and then multiply it by the trailing variables and radical. 9 minus 4 equals 5,
so this is our final result.